all right the broncos uh trying to turn
their season around they had that great
comeback win
over the chargers on sunday there was an
announcement today that both john elway
and joe ellis the guys who are
essentially running that franchise until
an owner is appointed
from pat bollin's family both have
tested positive for covet 19.
and it's just an indication that look
the virus is out there
and the nfl said on sunday they're
seeing an increase among the tier three
individuals who aren't part of the
actual nucleus of the team but
work around the team and provide
services to the team
they're seeing increases just like we're
seeing them throughout society
and as we get to cold and flu season the
numbers keep going up i know people are
numb to it but the numbers keep going up
and this is just a
a product of that reality people are
going to get it
no matter how careful people are sharing
yes they are mike and we saw it with the
broncos last week they were without
their defensive coordinator ed donatell
and
and without offensive line coach mike
munchak uh
covet protocols for them and you know
graham glasgow has it so it's been
in their facility it's been around and
it's knocked some people out and
unfortunately for them their leadership
and now is out of the building and
recouping uh at home in isolation
and the good news for the broncos today
actually it emerged last night von
miller
announcing that despite that ankle
injury that we thought would knock him
out for the season he will be back
hear it directly from him here he is
i'm feeling good man my ankle feeling
good i'm straight
i'm feeling real good man hopefully a
couple weeks
say about like three weeks to a month
i should be ready to go yeah
yeah i plan on coming back this year
he's gonna be ready in three or four
weeks and you know the broncos right now
with that win
on sunday they're they're in the mix for
the seventh seed
or the eighth seed if there is an eighth
seed in the afc at three and four
there's always that team i say this
every year around thanksgiving that's
hovering around four and four four and
five
five and four five and five and they
they they have it all fall together
and in drew lock if he can stay healthy
they have a guy who
who i think could could lead them to a
good place if they get von miller back
that's gonna make that defense even
better shireen
yeah he had his surgery september 11th
mike and he did say in october that if i
can play i'm coming back i don't care
where we are in the standings but it
looks like they're going to be
in it at least for that last wild card
spot
for a while now so that gives him hope
to come back and mike you've talked a
lot about what a big year this would be
for him to come back
if he can come back with his contract
and and what the numbers are for next
year
the broncos need to see something for
him he had a down year last year and
then the injuries this year
he needs to show him something if he
gets a chance to come back
he's always been very aware of the
reality that when he gets to the out
years of the contract he's in jeopardy
of being traded or
cut and i think it's important to him to
show
everyone the broncos first and foremost
but then any other potentially
interested team that he still got it
because
the broncos probably will be looking at
all options in the offseason as they get
to that point in the contract where
there's no cap consequence
you've got a big cap number and next
year the salary cap for all
teams likely to be in the range of 175
million they may have to make a decision
about
von miller hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports